or je voulais dit il faut qu'on apprenne
à nos enfants à s'ennuyer ça peut
paraître paradoxal pourquoi est-ce qu'on
doit apprendre à nos enfants à s'ennuyer
au 21ème siècle dit moi nico l'artiste
s'il vous plaît parce que c'est
important dans ces moments là justement
où ils ne font rien de se brancher sur
eux et d'essayer effectivement de
laisser vagabonder leur esprit leur
permettent de savoir ce qui leur ferait
plaisir qu'ils soient capables à cet
instant d'être à la fois à l'intérieur
d'eux pour sentir cet ennui et cette
sensation d'un vide et pas avoir sans
cesse des choses à faire les unes
derrière les autres qui ne leur
permettent pas de se brancher sur eux et
surtout ne pas être créatif nicole vous
avez deux papas lui samuel et alexandre
vous êtes bien bien bien entouré il boit
vos paroles je voyais et samuel akessé
vous êtes papa de miley n'est et léa 9
ans et 6 ans ou leur apprenez à oui on
essaye j'ai la chance d'avoir une femme
instit institutrice qui qui connaît un
petit peu aussi des besoins et la
nécessité de savoir s'ennuyer pour créer
d'imagination donc on essaye autant que
faire se peut de les stimuler là dessus
moi souvent je les lâche dans un champ
alors disons allez vous amuser avec les
fleurs les soustrait les criquets les
papillons et bien souvent au début
savent pas quoi faire mais au bout de
cinq minutes on n'arrive pas à les
sortir de de ce petit jardin à quoi ces
jeunes artistes
je trouve ça fabuleux en fait que les
parents un stimule à la fois la
créativité mais surtout la sensorialité
de leurs enfants
on parlait du visuel des oiseaux là je
peux parler peut-être du tactile des
fleurs de l'olf actifs
c'est un immense cadeau pour les adultes
au futur nicole soyons concrets si par
exemple mes enfants sont indécis cim 10
jours pascal recettes régenter tout ça
mais moi je suis sur mon écran
j'ai des copains et les copines et
cetera on a autre chose à faire quoi
mais il peut ya voir les copains et les
copines c'est pas franchement gênant
l'objectif c'est qu'il n'y ait pas
d'emploi du temps ou à 14h tu fais ça à
15h tu fais ça à 16h30 tu fais ça et où
on permet effectivement aux enfants à
des moments de dire écoute là le
principe c'est à table est sale pas dire
qu'on supprime les tables un tas mais
voilà qu'est ce qui te ferait plaisir
de quoi tueur est en vie qu'est ce que
tu as envie de faire les tout de suite
alex papa d'alice et sasha huit et douze
ans pour être très précis je le vois
sourire depuis tout à l'heure vous
sentez concerné ah oui on est tous
concernés on a tous un rythme pour
beaucoup on a même des rythmes de vie
qui sont très on est plus à zoner nous
dans le dans le train de l'activité et
c'est vrai que
avant avant de pouvoir en seigner ça aux
enfants il faut déjà une par an voilà
les chiens font pas des chats c'est ce
qu'on dit c'est à un énorme celui-ci je
crois qu'on est dans une société qui a
énormément peur du vide et on est dans
une hyperactivité une hyperstimulation
et je pense que on transmet ça et c'est
très juste en transe mais ça à nos
enfants sans s'en rendre compte
or c'est maintenant quand ils sont
petits que fectivement les connexions
des remixes sont au top et c'est là
maintenant qu'il faut de la stimulation
dans l'ennui le permet double question
la première comme vous dites il son
petit moi ça me parle pas c'est quel âge
et puis la seconde franchement on a vite
fait de se faire envoyer promener par
ses enfants qui me disent de roquettes
et très gentil mais moi ça va tout va
bien oui non peut partager les choses a
vécu justement sur cette notion là on
peut décider que on va aller observer
les oiseaux ensemble on peut dire que
c'est un moment effectivement autant
qu'on ne voit pas il ya une forme
d'ennui mais simplement faut les faire
parler
et sur la jeune école alors enfin je
sais pas il faut commencer très jeune
très bébé en fait je pense que c'est
important de leur mettre des choses dans
les doigts de leur faire sentir des
parfums de s'arranger effectivement
est-ce qu' il soit pas sans cesse en
train de courir après l'activité et
c'est jusqu'à alors à l'adolescence
après c'est plus compliqué oui mais il
faut le faire bien avant oui mais il
faut aussi que le parent accepte ça on
va se promener
voilà on est au bord de mer où on se
promène on va avoir un jeu qu'on cherche
des coquillages ensemble est-ce qu'on en
parle
est ce qu'on décide lequel est le plus
beau voilà il faut s'associer à ça ça
veut dire que nos enfants ont besoin de
temps libre pour se développer comme
absolument créativité si tu as un
élément clé un la créativité les
vagabondages de l'esprit c'est ce qui
permet de se brancher à la fois sur soi
sur l'instant présent et sur notre envie
et si on ne sait pas faire ça on est des
adultes qui se font balader
on parlait tout à l'heure avec samuel de
votre exemple avec vos enfants de
sensorialité de les faire respirer
dehors ça c'est important d'écoles un
fondamentalement important je pense que
les parents se rendent pas compte à quel
point le fait que eux-mêmes se branchent
sur l'instant présent sans avoir
l'esprit qui courte
jour devant ça montre aux enfants qu'on
peut palper le goût de la vie parce que
si on donne pas ça à nos enfants
on a tout faux